it's still a very famous experiment and
in fact far more people have heard about
Schrodinger's cat than have any idea who
is Schrodinger or what the cat was doing
Schrodinger's cat is what physicists
call a thought experiment what's called
a Gedanken thought experiment from the
German thought one I know this is an
experiment that you'd like to do and you
can talk about the consequences but
could you never do in practice like what
would happen to the earth when it was
going round around if the Sun
disappeared you could never make the Sun
disappear but you could still calculate
what would happen to the earth
Schrodinger was an Austrian physicist
who when the Nazis invaded Austria fled
to the UK and then to Dublin waking add
quite a colorful career and actually
fathered an illegitimate child but
that's nothing to do with his cat in the
cat experiment was something he proposed
to try and explain an idea or how stupid
he thought one of the ideas that had
been proposed by quantum physicists
working in Copenhagen who were
discussing how if you couldn't observe
something which had two possible states
the two states could be muddled together
so you couldn't tell which was which
Schrodinger's cat is a thought
experiment in which a cat is put in a
box showing his cat thought experiment
well it goes something like this
imagine you have a cat I'm sorry this is
not a very good model but you can
imagine this is a cat which can either
be alive or dead and his idea was that
you have a steel box which can be closed
so that the hole it can be cut off
completely from the outside and nobody
not even physicists can see inside so
the idea is that you put the cat in the
box and at the same time you put inside
a small vessel that contains a tiny
amount of a radioactive material and the
radioactive material has a few atoms and
you choose the number of atoms so that
during a period of say an hour there's a
50% chance that one of them might decay
radioactively and give out a particle
so you put that in the box so now you
have the cat the radioactive material
you then take a Geiger counter here we
have a very fine Geiger counter which
can detect whether the radioactive decay
has taken place or not and then and this
is the cunning part you connect the
guide counter to hammer which if it
detects something it will break a small
glass container containing cyanide which
is poisonous which will come out and
kill the cat
so we now close the lid and we start
timeing so we know that while the box is
closed inside during the period of one
hour there's a chance that a radioactive
decay might take place we there's no way
of us predicting there are only
equations we write down how much physics
we try to do that is a quantum process
and we simply can't predict it and if it
takes place the Geiger counter triggers
gets the hammer the hammer smashes the
cyanide and the cat dies the key
question that Schrodinger asked or the
key Gedanken experiment that he put
forward is well think about what is the
state of the cat before you open the box
since we don't know whether the
radioactive decay has taken place or not
under this idea proposed by the people
in Copenhagen the cat doesn't know
whether it is dead or alive you've got
no way of knowing whether the cat in the
box is alive or dead quantum
mechanically what you would see is that
the cat is in a superposition of states
it's both alive and dead and it's only
when the our app is up and we open the
door that we then determine whether the
cat is dead or alive but while the door
is shut the cat is in this mixture of
dead and alive State
now the point of this experiment at
least as far as I know as a chemist was
that trading has said this is a crazy
idea you can't have a cat that is dead
or alive now
Shirley's idea was to bring this strange
quantum business to bring it patch to
the general public but also to make it
the thing more real and relevant the
genius of this experiment and why people
have thought about it so long and still
get excited is because it links and at
an event on the atomic scale one atom
disintegrating or not to something that
everybody can understand the cat being
dead or alive so you can't tell the
cat's dead
or it's alive I mean clearly the cat is
never half dead and half alive is either
alive and dead and I think the
usefulness of the of a showing us cat
story is a caution it's really a
cautionary tale that we have to use
different rules of thinking when we're
dealing with everyday objects like cats
and quantum objects so Schrodinger came
up with this actually to try and show
the the pitfalls with some elements of
the quantum mechanical concept because
it is such a very strange concept he
wanted to try and show the ludicrousness
of thinking like this the idea that the
cat is in two separate states at the
same time it's both alive and dead and
this was really that that's the
Copenhagen interpretation that you can
have this superposition of states
showing I really wanted to show that
that wasn't the case and that was just
ludicrous to think like that but the
problem is we've done experiments and at
this quantum level that's how matter
behaves our everyday notions of things
being a well-defined States for
large-scale objects just do not apply
the quantum level and we have to use
just other ways of thinking and that's
what quantum mechanics is I mean there
are lots and lots of examples the one
probably the most famous one is the
electron has a spin it in some sense
behaves like a little tiny spinning top
but it's a weird quantum mechanical kind
of spin so it has all sorts of strange
properties
but you can think of an electron as a
little spinning top and so one of the
classic sort of superpose states you can
have is you can actually you know there
are two ways that spin think and spin
right it can go clockwise or
anti-clockwise you can actually have an
electron that hasn't yet made up its
mind which state it's in so it actually
is in a superpose state where it's both
rotating one way and rotating the other
way at the same time and it's only when
you do an experiment to actually measure
the properties of that electron that it
collapses into one state or the other so
it spins clockwise or anti-clockwise and
so that's an example of a quantum
mechanical object which is can
fundamentally be in two states at the
same time Einstein got very excited
about this and wrote two Schrodinger
later except that in Einstein's case he
imagined it with explosives rather than
cyanide which perhaps might be more
dramatic but is no good because if the
explosive went off it would destroy the
box so it would spoil the idea of the
experiments I thought answer I was
clever that's a stupid idea well perhaps
he had the strongbox